huge news rocked the music world over
the weekend the 1970s songwriter joni
mitchell announced that she will be
following neil young and removing her
music from spotify until joe rogan and
the scientists that he interviews are
censored from the platform
joni mitchell who has not been in the
news in at least 40 years and who many
people in this audience have probably
never even heard of will be removing her
entire catalog including the four songs
that anyone can name
immediately
which inspired me
and which is why i am announcing today
my intention to announce that i too will
be taking my content off of spotify in
order to bring attention to myself i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from frank who
says
shouldn't biden say he's nominating a
black body that's true
if you want to be
really politically correct these days
you're not even supposed to just refer
to black people or people of color it's
supposed to be black bodies this was a a
strange term popularized by writers such
as ton heezy coates to imply that black
people don't have any souls that that is
the the preferred term these days and it
would actually be fitting if we're
talking about leftist judicial nominees
because while they obviously have bodies
regardless of their sex or race they do
not appear to have
minds they do not appear to have much
consciousness they just do whatever the
libs program them to do so that would be
the right term good that's a very good
point it does make you a little bit
nervous about the future when you want
to plan for your future i would
recommend you check out alto ira
cryptocurrency may represent the future
of money it's one of the most exciting
investment opportunities to come around
for some time but
what about taxes
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes
get into investing in crypto
do it in a tax advantage retirement
account alto's crypto ira is the easiest
way to get crypto into an ira trade all
you want without the tax headache you
create an account in just a few minutes
and invest with as little as 10 bucks
no setup charges either get secured
trading 24 7 through alto's integration
with coinbase there are 80 plus coins
available including bitcoin ethereum and
cardano plus there are multiple ways to
fund your account you make a cash
contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira or roll over an old 401 k
open an alto crypto ira account with as
little as 10 bucks join today at altoira
dot com michael that is a l t o i r a
dot com slash michael mich ael start
investing in cryptocurrency today that
is alto ira dot com slash michael
all weekend
all weekend i had something really
nagging at me it wasn't merely the idea
that joe rogan most popular broadcaster
in the world he might be booted off of
a major platform simply for telling the
truth
and and exposing people to different
points of view from very serious
scientists from very
serious and and respected people but
people who
disagree with the prevailing liberal
narrative he might be kicked off well we
might be kicked off too
rogan goes we all go it's only a matter
of time if they can boot him they can
boot all of us but i had something
nagging me even worse than that
namely neil young's music i couldn't get
it out of my head
all weekend i'd pick up a ukulele i'd
sit down at my piano and i'd play these
neil young management
i just i couldn't stop i had these neil
young songs in my head i haven't thought
of neil young
in
at least a decade
and then joni mitchell
joni mitchell
if you can
name joni mitchell songs which for many
of the millennials and certainly the
zoomers in the audience probably you
can't name all that many she was really
popular in the 70s but she didn't remain
particularly popular later
i had those songs in my head too i've
looked at love from both sides and all i
thought why why are these songs in my
head
oh right it's because of this genius pr
stunt
it was it is a genius pr stunt i'm i'm
not doubting that neil young and joni
mitchell really do want to censor people
who disagree with them i'm sure they do
they want to censor people who
dissent from dr fauci in the ruling
class they are now propagandists for the
ruling class and they don't like it when
people speak truth to power
and so they want to shut them up i'm
sure but there's also a genius
capitalist
self-interested motive here which is
that people are talking about these
singers again
for the first time in a very long time
you can expect to see many more
announcements last night sweet little
lisa turned to me we were sitting on the
couch she goes oh no
oh no mag i said yeah girl what's going
on mag did you know that and she named
someone i had never heard of
in my
he's decided he's going to take all of
his audio books off of spotify until
they get rid of joe rogan this was a guy
no i had never heard of she had never
heard of i'm sure no one had ever heard
of but he just wanted to grab a headline
so i said that's good good for me too
let's do it
this show i'm gonna i'm not gonna take
the show off spotify but i'm gonna
announce
that this show
is going off of spotify until they
censor rogan how dare they let rogan
talk to scientists
some people are saying about neil young
and joni mitchell they've changed oh my
gosh 60s and 70s neil young and joni
mitchell they would be ashamed of neil
young and joni mitchell today they used
to be for free speech now they're for
censorship
they haven't changed joni mitchell was
always actually relatively conservative
given the musicians of that era
she uh when she was in an unexpected
pregnancy couldn't take care of her kid
she did not get an abortion she put the
baby up for adoption she wouldn't get
that was great she she wasn't anti-war i
think she supported the uso during
vietnam so she was relatively better but
she's on the side of these leftists
censoring conservatives
which they always were
they always were that was everyone's for
censorship you might pretend that you're
not for censorship you are you're for
censoring certain things all
i say this frequently all societies have
limits
it seemed like these hippies were pro
free speech in the 60s because the
prevailing culture was conservative and
so they wanted to to break the taboos
and the standards of that day and spout
their nonsense but now they're in
control the liberals control the entire
culture and so they're enforcing the
standards
and now we're the ones who seem like
we're pro free speech
and we think that you should be able to
say and do whatever you want but we
don't believe that either we just all
have we have different sets of standards
and right now the libs are winning
this is
and they're pushing this really hard by
the way
you want to see the anatomy of a fake
news headline
this was a headline in variety magazine
trade magazine in hollywood this was
syndicated into yahoo
said spotify lost more than two billion
dollars in market value after neil young
pulled his music over joe rogan's
podcast
this is this should be framed as a fake
news article par excellence
it's so effective because
it's technically
almost kind of true
if you just look at the days
sometime around when neil young made his
announcement
the spotify number went down
spotify stock down
that's true
but correlation is not causation the
reason that spotify lost two billion
dollars in market value
is because the entire market was down
significantly
virtually every company lost a ton of
market value if you just look at the one
or two day period
did ge lose value because neil young
said he was going to pull his music from
spotify
did
i don't know did did ford motor company
lose value did microsoft lose value
because no of course not
it went down and actually it's even
crazier than that because if you look
specifically after the in the two days
after neil young made his announcement
spotify actually ticked up a little bit
so maybe that should be evidence that
neil young was dragging down spotify and
the market loves rogan or really maybe
there's just no correlation here the
scary part though is the libs are
circling the wagons on this
the the news media are in on it big tech
is slowly in on it the culture obviously
and the public health establishment
which is the
the puppet master in this whole thing
right everybody joni mitchell
neil young they're all doing fauci's
bidding here and saying we can't dissent
against the the ruling class in the
bureaucracy
so it's good that spotify for now is
standing up for rogan i'm not sure that
that lasts i do think that we need to
defend joe rogan at all costs
defend rogan if rogan goes they're
coming for the rest of us
too
and and what's so frustrating about it
is it's not even the
apparent hypocrisy on free speech it's
not even
the the fact that
uh joe rogan
and the guests that rogan brings on have
more credibility than dr fauci or
rochelle wallensky because because fauci
and wallensky and joe biden have been
caught in so many lies on covid it's the
fact that neil young and joni mitchell
are just wrong
on the merits they're wrong on the
substance
here the message that we are getting
from our public health genius experts
in recent weeks is that everyone needs
to take not just the vaccine but many
doses of the vaccine three four five
shots there should really not be any
exceptions
not just old people not just sick people
but young healthy people even little
kids need to take the vaccine it's
totally 100 safe it's totally effective
never mind any of the reports to the
contrary pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain and then you get news
like this out of sweden
which is
no longer recommending that kids take
the vaccine
sweden will not recommend covid19
vaccines for kids 5 to 11
to say nothing of kids under 5.
they say quote we are now focusing on
the medical benefits of the individual
child and we don't see that the benefits
are great enough for us to recommend for
the whole group this is according to
britta bjorklund of the public health
agency in sweden
she said we don't see
that we
that we
we we want to vaccinate a whole group of
children for the sake of society
we want to see a clear benefit for the
children themselves and the individual
child so that's why we don't recommend
it for the moment
it's a great
this is a great
observation
they're saying we believe in the public
health establishment that we need to
look at the health benefits to the child
the child who we're making take this
experimental injection
and so we're not saying that the
vaccines are going to kill the kids
we're not even necessarily saying that
the vaccines are
extremely dangerous sure there are side
effects like there are to all medical
interventions but we're not we're just
saying there's no health benefit that we
see
so if there's no clear health benefit
we're not going to
vaccinate all of these kids
we're not going to just focus on the
politics here we're going to focus on
the medical science for for the
individual for the kids themselves
meanwhile the fouchies and the
wallenskis and the american public
health establishment they say who cares
about any of that who cares if there's
not much benefit politically it's a good
thing to do so we're going to do it
huge difference more evidence
of something that we've known from the
very beginning that dr fauci is
politician first
scientist
maybe second or third or fourth or fifth
ethics all the way down in the gutter
now speaking of health if you want to
start feeling healthy again especially
in this new year i would strongly
recommend you go check out echelon
long-time listeners to this show know
that i am allergic to going to the gym i
have not been to the gym
i think probably since the obama
administration i i hate it because you
have to drive what 20 minutes to the gym
then you go you get out you get on the
equipment you
you do your thing for however long then
you go you got to
change shower get back drive 20. it just
takes too long what if you bring the gym
home that's what echelon does echelon
fitness is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment the workout community
and an instructor's motivation right in
the comfort and privacy of your own home
with echelon fitness you can work at any
time day or night and crush your fitness
goals pick your class climb the
leaderboard cheer each other on and give
it your all echelon fitness's full range
of affordable workout equipment
including stationary bikes smart rowers
sleek fitness screens and the auto
folding treadmill are all connected to
provide the echelon fitness experience
right now for a limited time our
listeners get up to 650 off msrp i love
my echelon i really really recommend
this to get the exclusive podcast
discount text knowles canadawles to
818181
text knowles right now do it right now
if you're even slightly somewhat
interested i'm telling you you will not
regret it text knowles kwles to 81 81 81
to get up to 650 off msrp text knowles
to 818181 message and data rates may
apply terms available at echelonfit.com
sms membership sold separately
dr fauci
is
disagreeing with the swedish scientists
i'm not sure they're even disagreeing
on
the the science itself
they're disagreeing on the policy
sweden says we're not going to force
kids
to take the covet vaccine fauci says
yes we will fauci says quote
uh children two to four years old will
require three shots
of the pfizer coveted vaccine
it turned out that the other dose namely
the other group from 24 months to four
years old did not yet reach the level of
non-inferiority
so the studies are continued
it looks like it will be a three dose
regimen i don't think we can predict
when we will see an emergency you
thought use authorization with that
because the company is still putting the
data before the fda but it's going to be
a three dose regimen for the kids
uh actually no it's going to be a zero
dose regimen for my kids dr fauci
because i don't trust you i don't trust
you at all because you've you've lied
many times you've gotten things wrong
even if i'm gonna take a more charitable
view
of some of your dishonesty and say maybe
you didn't intend to deceive you were
just dumb and got it wrong and ignorant
but either way
i ain't trusting you
fauci has proven this for decades since
the 80s since aids since he took over
niaid in the mid 1980s that he is a
politician first
he is a scientist second
and he is an ethicist least of all his
ethics are absolute trash
i think you would be crazy
to listen to this guy at this point
especially when we're talking about your
kids
especially given everything this guy's
gotten wrong you would have to it is
true parental negligence
to trust your kids to this
deceitful
jerk
this power mad
monster
i don't want to put too fine a point on
it
this is a great issue for the gop
looking at november
what's the gop going to be able to
promise come november we're told it's
going to be a red wave
the republicans are going to retake the
house uh-huh i've heard that before
republicans are going to retake the
house under a democrat presidency and
what happens nothing remember this the
tea party 2010 it's going to be a wave
election we're we're going to put
boehner we're going to make boehner the
speaker and then it'll all be great well
what happened nothing
one because boehner was a weak speaker
of the house two because the democrats
at the presidency
so what are you gonna do all you can do
is obstruct
you can't really do much of anything
the one thing you can do
is call investigations
the one thing you can do
is make a mess of things like the budget
we should do both of those
i want every republican
running in any even somewhat
conservative district
to promise me that if the republicans
retake the house they are going to
subpoena fouchy they're going to drag
him before congress they are going to
make his life
miserable they're going to get to the
bottom of his corruption they're going
to make him answer for his lies and his
deception
and then
when they're playing around with the
budget i want them to zero out his
salary
the the house gop can't fire fouchy
that's up to the executive
but they can zero out his salary they've
got the power of the purse they should
use it i want i want
a promise from all these house gop
candidates
that in the 90s and 2000s and and even i
think it still exists today there was
the tax payer protection pledge rover
norquist was behind it and said i
promised not to raise taxes
and he would make all the candidates
none of the candidates wanted to sign it
because they all wanted the opportunity
to raise taxes later i want that for
fouchy
i will
the the public health protection pledge
that's what i want i'm calling for it
the michael knowles public health
protection pledge i will drag fouchy
before congress for for testimony and
investigations and i will zero out his
salary get it done print it out send it
to every congressional candidate around
the country
you want to talk about the well-being of
children
under the left's rule
there is a story out of los angeles that
i did not believe was real
i thought this clearly this is either
the babylon bee or this is some
sensationalist headline it's not real
here's what the headline said said
that a 26 year old male child molester
was going to be sentenced
two years imprisonment
in a female
juvenile detention center
because of la's far left
d.a the prosecutor there george gascon i
said that's not possible hold on what
are you you're telling me that a guy is
a child molester
this guy molested little girls and so to
punish him
you're going to send him to a facility
full of little girls
that sounds like you're rewarding him
that sounds like you're sending him to
disney world
that's
how is that
how is that just how is that legal how
is that punishment
that's sick but this is a real story
james tubbs
when he was two weeks shy of his 18th
birthday
grabbed a girl by the neck
dragged her into a bathroom stall
you can use your imagination there's
evidence that he molested two other
little girls
he was finally connected with this case
years later
but la's far left george soros-funded
district attorney george gascon
refused to try him as an adult
because when he committed the crime
years ago he was two weeks shy of his
18th birthday so this 26 year old
degenerate pervert
is being tried
as a minor
okay after he gets arrested
this guy's trying to figure out how he
can get out of punishment
so he decides because we are living in
clown world right now he decides he's
going to start identifying as a woman
only this doesn't happen before he gets
arrested by the way so only after he
gets raised he says okay i'm hannah now
call me hannah
so james tubbs says okay i am
identifying as a girl
as a woman
and the district attorney is going to
identify me as a child so i
and
an old not old he's a young man but he's
a man he's an adult man i an adult man
i'm going to be identified as a little
girl
and so i'm not going to go to prison for
a really long time not going to go to
prison at all i'm going to go to
a juvenile detention facility
with a bunch of little girls
and here's the kicker this is the this
is the cherry on on top of this
clown sunday
the assistant district attorney john
hatami in los angeles disagrees with the
d.a george gascon's decision here to
to
try james tubbs as a minor he says tubbs
is 26 years old
unlike george gascon's false narrative
she is not a kid
she is not a kid she is not a she she's
a he
buddy are you kidding me
you're willing to go this far and say
hey the 26 year old is not really a 17
year old yeah the
chick isn't a chick pal
the chick is a dude
frankly that's even crazier than a 26
year old being treated like a 17 year
old i think it's crazier to treat a male
child molester like a woman
james tubbs obviously
should be castrated and imprisoned for
life
minimum
minimum
this would that that perspective would
not have been controversial even 20
years ago
now that's shocking michael you're being
so provocative oh here comes the right
wing crazy you believe that
grown male child molesters shouldn't get
to live with little girls for two years
you believe that that child molesters
shouldn't be castrated and sent to
prison
at the minimum this guy should be
castrated and imprisoned for life
frankly the same goes for george gascon
okay because this james tubbs is
obviously a pervert he's obviously a
degenerate and a pervert who needs very
severe punishment to possibly
one for the demands of justice but two
to hopefully in any way rehabilitate him
reform him
same goes for for the d.a
the d.a seems like a bigger pervert than
james tubbs in some ways because the d.a
is supposed to know better he's he's in
charge of public authority
this james tubbs is one sick puppy
george gascon is supposed to be in his
right mind and yet he's the one
indulging this and encouraging this sort
of thing
even the good guy in this story is
peddling delusion
and you know what
this is the natural conclusion
of the myths of our age this is the
natural conclusion of two delusions that
we are living under right now
one of them is the over-incarceration
delusion the other one is the
transgender delusion
the one delusion says we've got too many
people in prison in america
never mind that crime's going through
the roof we've got too many people the
pro we need to let criminals out of
prison
okay if you believe that then you're
going to do everything you can to not
send people to prison including trying
people who are adults
as juveniles where that's plausible
including giving people way lighter
sentences
instead of imprisoning this guy for
decades now just a couple years in a
little girls facility and transgenderism
because
if if this guy says that he's a woman
then he really is a woman according to
that delusion and so you have to put him
in a girl's facility
so he's got to go to the women's
facility and because we it's a mass
incarceration we got to put them in the
juvenile facility
and as a result of those two
allegedly compassionate delusions we're
living under
some disgusting degenerate pervert 26
year old child molester is going to live
with little girls
something has gone seriously wrong in a
country that believes that and i i have
i have less sympathy for the d.a
than i have for the for the
criminal himself
you know lately there has been a war on
the truth i'm not telling you anything
you don't know specifically a war on
truth spoken by individuals like dr
robert malone malone has been removed
from nearly all major social media
platforms for his public skepticism of
the covid vaccine he's not only an
esteemed virologist and immunologist
he's also one of the pioneers of the
mrna vaccines themselves after going
viral for his recent interview on joe
rogan's podcast his insights cannot be
silenced any longer so our very own
candice owens sat down for three and a
half hours with dr malone
she does not leave any stone unturned
this interview will be available
exclusively at dailywire.com tomorrow
february 1st if you don't already have a
daily wire membership head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe right now use
code science for 25 off your membership
the episode will premiere tomorrow at
9pm eastern 8pm central also you know
matt has become a number one lgbt author
and spokesman in the world especially
after that dr phil interview that ended
up going viral if you have not seen it
yet i highly recommend you check it out
and if you haven't gotten his
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus it can be reserved on amazon
we'll be right back with a lot more
conservatives need to go all in
on the transgender stuff go all in
i've been saying this for
some time now there are three issues
that really i guess four issues though
two are kind of related
where conservatives have a huge
opportunity because there is a gigantic
chasm between what the public believes
and what elite politicians believe led
by the democrats because the democrats
are the elite political party
but also promoted by some elite
republicans who are the court jesters in
the kingdom of liberalism who they're
the kind of squishy loser republicans
who just exist to do whatever whatever
the libs ultimately want them to do so
those issues are
crime
the people want to lock up more
criminals the elite politicians want to
let pilot want to like criminals out of
prison
so go in on that arresting criminals
that's a that's a winner
that's immigration
the majority of americans want to
drastically reduce immigration legal and
illegal immigration elite politicians in
both parties led by the democrats though
want much more immigration and in some
cases illegal immigration
and
education
majority of americans believe that
parents should have a say in how their
kids are raised
the elite politicians say no you don't
and we're not even just talking about
reading writing and arithmetic we're
talking about what we're going to jab
into your kid's arm we're talking about
the whole upbringing of your child
that's what gave us the victory for glen
younkin in virginia that issue of
immigration
it's a basic
fact of life that parents have a right
to some say over how their kids are
raised and the democrats and the elite
republicans are now denying that okay
and then the related issue
is transgenderism because one of the big
issues in these schools this is what
took over loudoun county was this
transgender ideology the fact that
parents now have to send their kids to
school their little boy to school
knowing that he's being taught
at age five four three years old he's
being taught that if he wants to be a
little girl he is a little girl
and that if he says he's a little girl
the parents have no right to say no
that is the vast majority of americans
think that's evil
terrible unacceptable
elite politicians in the democratic
party and even some republicans i think
it's i think it's fine or great
okay we need to
capitalize on that
even sean penn you know sean penn
one of the furthest left actors in the
country this is a guy who palled around
with hugo chavez
this is a guy who's sexually pretty
open-minded he played harvey milk who
was a complete degenerate creepy
pederast politician in san francisco who
has been whitewashed as the martin
luther king of gay rights
he's obviously a man of the left sean
penn and he just came out and he said
you know i think men in america are kind
of sissies i think they're becoming too
feminized sean penn wrote
he said this in an interview promoting a
new movie he said
i'm in the club that believes that men
in american culture have become wildly
feminized i don't think that being a
brute or having insensitivity or
disrespect for women has anything to do
with masculinity or ever did but i don't
think that in order to be fair to women
we should become them
right he's said similar things before he
said there are a lot of i think cowardly
genes that lead to people surrendering
their genes the first one is
g-e-n-e-s second was j-e-a-n-s
to surrendering their genes and putting
on a skirt i have these very strong
women in my life who do not take
masculinity as a sign of oppression
toward them
this is proof this is the sean penn
proof
that sex and gender are huge winning
issues for
republicans
even
big libs like sean penn understand this
that men are not women
the early conservative arguments on the
sexual revolution hey maybe this free
love's not such a great idea hey maybe
contraception everywhere is not even
abortion maybe that's not terrific maybe
no fault divorce is going to harm
society
this isn't great maybe
the the extremes of the lgbt movement
redefining marriage that's probably not
great it was very difficult for people
in the middle
for people who are independent voters
for soft liberals even for soft
conservatives to understand that
because they would say
whatever what does it hurt me yeah it's
a little weird that johnny and
and phil or
want to
call their union marriage but whatever
it doesn't hurt me i don't care we've
all got a gay cousin or something it's
fine you know whatever
conservatives would say guys you're
missing the
the premises here that this is a very
slippery slope and it's going to lead to
absolute sexual disorientation and chaos
and it's going to lead to really creepy
stuff
and they'll say no come on you're
worrying it's a slippery slope fallacy
okay it was easy for
the libs
to deny that for a long time now we've
got
26 year old dudes putting on skirts
getting tried and sentenced as little
girls
and it's just silly we just know it's
ridiculous
men who dress up like women
look ridiculous
this is why drag was
always kind of funny
do you remember rudy giuliani
rudy giuliani on saturday night live
showed up in drag one time with donald
trump
it was funny it's funny to see a dude
dress up like a chick because a dude is
not supposed to dress up like a chick
now we are told it's very sincere it's
very earnest it's very it's how dare you
question that no it's it's still funny
it's still incongruous
but a lot of elite republicans i think
oh i don't want to seem insensitive
oh i don't want to seem like bigoted
like a phobe like an ist
the that
don't pay don't pay any attention to
what you're seeing on tv don't pay any
attention to what you're hearing from
the elite press the corporate press the
regime propagandists
the vast majority of americans know this
is completely insane if you just stay
that say that with a clear voice you're
going to bring people along with you
you're going to persuade people you
don't even need to persuade them they
already believe it we're not talking
about rock ribbed right wingers we're
not talking about mussolini okay we're
talking about sean freaking
pen
but republicans
they want to clutch defeat from the jaws
of victory they're not they're not going
to want to run on it but they should
they should glenn younkin started out as
a chamber of commerce just cut my taxes
kind of republican in virginia and he
was going to lose and then at the end of
the campaign he made it about
transgenderism and critical race theory
and education and real divisive tough
cultural issues and what happened he won
and he should have won because people
care about those things
i like a tax cut as much as the next guy
people are not waking up in a cold sweat
in the middle of the night because of
the marginal tax rate
the transgender thing is so weird and it
is sweeping
the country by storm not even all the
way transgender just this kind of weird
sexual confusion you remember you
remember last week
mars corporation the candy company
made the decision
to
turn the green m m previously the
sexiest piece of candy in the culture
they decided to turn her into a
flat-shoed
feminist
do you remember that they were going to
make her less sexy and
conservatives said wait why are you
making the green m m less sexy and then
the left left said why do you think a
piece of candy is sexy and i said well
i'm not saying i'm not saying
the candy itself is but they
there's something wrong
with a culture that won't allow things
to be
hot or scintillating or sexy no no no
one's really
attracted to a piece of candy except
maybe this 26 year old pervert up that's
being tried as a child in los angeles
but very few people think that the piece
of candy is sexy
but
when we represent things in art when we
when we want to make things attractive
in art whether it's in marketing or
whether it's in entertainment or whether
it's in high art
we have traditionally
brought them closer to objective
standards of beauty traditional
standards of beauty now we seem to be
doing the opposite in all of our
marketing
the models are intentionally not hot
they're much uglier
even in the cartoons there there was a a
brief controversy when there was the
space jam sequel last year and the hot
sexy little bunny rabbit who previously
was made to look very voluptuous and hot
was made to not look hot anymore and to
look more androgynous and there was the
same kind of back and forth between the
left and the right then it happened with
the m ms now they're doing it to minnie
mouse disney has just announced that
minnie mouse is
practically speaking a frumpy lesbian
minnie mouse had been
one of the most famous cartoon
girlfriends
ever
to mickey
one of and i i i'm not afraid to say it
one of the hottest mice
in recorded history and now she is
wearing a pantsuit
and is made to resemble more
say a certain former secretary of state
and presidential candidate but and
certainly not
meant to look like marilyn monroe
disneyland paris tweeted out this photo
of
ms mouse's
miz not miss
not mrs miz very feminist very first
pantsuit which was designed by stella
mccartney they say that it looks like a
blue tuxedo i think the pantsuit looks
more like a pair of pajamas that your
mother might have purchased at t.j.maxx
okay it doesn't
which maybe is better than the pantsuit
i don't know this is all to celebrate
women's history month which is confusing
because i thought this was black history
month
i i'm not up to date on my liberal
liturgical calendar i thought women's
history month was in a month or two
whatever
the reason i bring it up is not merely
[Music]
or really at all because i care about
the sexiness of cartoons or or candies
the reason i bring it up is because we
are living in a cult of ugliness
we used to have a cult
of beauty
we used to be drawn toward beauty and we
used to try to make ourselves look
beautiful
and this can be taken to excess this can
be taken to such an extreme that people
develop disordered views of themselves
that would that's bad you don't want to
do that
but now we've taken it to the complete
opposite extreme where we're developing
other disordered habits we are
attempting to make ourselves ugly
through
mutilating ourselves through
overeating through dressing poorly
through
denying
de-sexing ourselves trying to make
ourselves look androgynous or like the
other sex
we're told almost that it's that it's
wrong to be beautiful that beauty is
somehow oppressive
and this this relates to the broader
political problem
we're living in a world now where the
truth is being censored
joe rogan brings on one of the pioneers
of the mrna vaccine to give his views of
the mrna vaccine
that's dangerous you can't have that
true statements about covid about the
virus
about certain
public health measures
about the vaccines true statements that
that later turn out to be true that even
the public health authorities will later
admit are true
for a long period of time or being
censored my very show when i've said
completely accurate things
has been taken down
and then six months later the cdc admits
i was right well whoopsie too bad
we're living in a time where the truth
is being suppressed
in favor of lies we're living in a time
in which
virtue is being suppressed in favor of
vice where we're told that vice is
actually virtue and the left virtue
signals
at a time where traditional
understanding is what the things that
are good to do or we're told that's bad
and things that are bad to do
obscenity wrath profanity
greed
we're told is really good
violence in some cases we're told
leftist violence actual terrorism you
target civilians to achieve a political
and we're told that's really good and
virtuous that's mostly peaceful
and we're living in a time where beauty
is being suppressed in favor of ugliness
which makes sense because the good the
true and the beautiful are the
transcendentals of being they're united
they have something to do with one
another
and so it's no surprise that when you
hate
truth and you hate goodness you're gonna
hate beauty also it's okay to be
beautiful it's okay little girls
you don't need to
you don't need to dress up like rambo
it's okay to want to be a disney
princess it's fine men it's okay to look
like a man it's not toxic
it's okay
to behave like a man it's fine
beauty is a good thing you don't when
you go look at art in a museum you don't
just need to look at the urinal in the
middle of the stall or some stupid
splotches on a canvas and try to pretend
that that's somehow beautiful when we
all know it's not it's okay to look at
the mona lisa it's okay to look at the
sistine chapel and say that's actually
beautiful that's objectively beautiful
it's more beautiful than the urinal on
the floor or the splotches on the canvas
it's not just a matter of preference
it's not just a matter of well your
truth and my truth might be different
what you think is good and what i think
is good maybe what i think is good you
think is bad and what you think is bad i
think is good so we can never know maybe
what i think is beautiful is what you
think is ugly or vice versa so it's all
subjective it's all relative right man
no actually we can know some things
because we have faculties of reason and
moral conscience and we not only need
the courage to articulate that we need
the courage to enforce that kind of
stuff or we're going to be living in a
culture full of lies full of vice and
full of ugliness
and frumpy little cartoon mice
and ugly little green m ms okay
and androgynous little bunny rabbits in
space jam and that's very very
frustrating
a lot of this is all is being peddled on
the identity
politics front
right if you if you disagree
with the prevailing views if you if you
articulate a more traditional view of
the good the true and the beautiful
you're called you're called oppressive a
fascist a white supremacist why i don't
know you're anti-this your anti-that
you're a phobe
this is another issue where republicans
just need to grab the bull by the horns
because the public across demographics
across races across geographies across
sexes
they agree with us the identity politics
thing is totally flopping you see this
nowhere more clearly than on joe biden's
recent decision to nominate a supreme
court justice not based on her
qualifications not based on her resume
not based on her character and integrity
but based on her genitals and the color
of her skin
jensaki was just asked this question uh
at the white house press briefing
there was a poll that showed that
majority of americans do not
support biden's decision to
pick a supreme court nominee just based
on race and sex that they actually think
the person should be picked based on his
or her qualifications the best person
for the job should get it
so even the sympathetic
reporters in in the white house the ones
who are on the side of joe biden
bring this question up and they say what
do you say to the americans who disagree
with this
there have already been conservative
commentators um
talking a bit about
why a black woman that's to commit to
that is is reverse racism or
some kind of signaling
um a virtual virtue signaling or
something like that what do you say to
people who are saying that that is
you know an inappropriate uh way to
to to set up prerequisites for who he's
going
uh jen i look this is so dumb and i hate
that i even have but some idiot
conservative commentators are
saying that there's like reverse racism
or something first of all it's not
reverse racism it's just racism there's
no such thing as reverse racism it's
just racism which they're changing the
definition of by the way we'll get to
that in one second second of all it's
not just conservative commentators
there's a pull out from abc ipsos
abc not not exactly the daily wire okay
not exactly some right wing outlet
showed that over three quarters of
americans
want biden to consider quote all
possible nominees only 23 percent want
him to automatically follow through on
picking a black woman
without considering
94
of of the country
only focusing on six percent the black
women in the country
americans
it's not that americans oppose a black
lady on the supreme court i suspect
americans very much want a black lady on
the supreme court
the reason that three more than
three-quarters of americans don't want
him to do it this way so you're talking
about a huge number of democrats here
too the reason they don't want him to do
it this way is because this way won't
let them feel good
there's a lie there's this total
canard that americans are racist and
they hate black people they want to keep
black people down that's bs every single
person in this country
with maybe i don't know four people is
an exception four people is would be my
guess people who actually just say i
hate black people i don't want them to
succeed at all
the other 330 million
really want black people to succeed
they they want to seem
they want to
be affirmed in their virtue of not
really caring about anyone's race
they want to be affirmed in their virtue
of of viewing all people
as the same equally dignified by god
made in the image of god
and joe biden
because he's so clumsy
took that away from them
people loved even many republicans loved
when obama got elected because they
could say we're not racist we're not a
racist country how do you think obama
got elected twice because this is
because america hates black people and
wants to keep them down i don't think so
barack obama was not qualified to be
president he had the thinnest resume of
any president in recent memory and they
elected him anyway because he was a
black guy and he ran as the historical
change candidate he didn't run on
anything in particular
he he was the he was the platform i am
barack obama i am the one i will heal
the earth i will bring the sea levels
down i will solve america's original sin
of of
racism right this was the ethos
of of the obama campaign and americans
loved it they gobbled it up
biden's taken that
sense of virtue away from americans here
though
because what he's saying is yeah black
women aren't the most qualified
and and if all things were equal i
wouldn't pick a black woman so i'm going
to make a concerted effort and i'm going
to take out all the other nominees and
i'm only going to consider black women
that way they have a chance
and
that that's really ugly people don't
like that very much not just
conservative commentators darling three
quarters of all americans so gensake
sort of kind of almost answers the
question
first we'd say that the fact that no
black woman has been nominated shows a
deficiency of the past election
processes not a lack of qualified
candidates to be nominated to the
supreme court i'd also note i've heard
that some conservatives may be fans of
president reagan
and when he former president reagan
and when he nominated sandra day
o'connor he said quote judge o'connor's
confirmation symbolizes the richness of
opportunity that still abides in america
opportunity that permits persons of any
sex age or any race from every section
and every walk of life to aspire and
achieve and a manner never before even
dreamed about in human history
completely misses the point the sandra
day o'connor comparison completely
misses the point
we all grant
that americans would love to see a black
woman on the court i guarantee you the
majority of americans if you took a poll
today would love to see a black woman on
the court
but they don't want to be told she was
picked because she's a black woman
because that doesn't make them feel
virtuous
what what reagan said was the
confirmation of justice o'connor shows
the richness of america and women can do
whatever
by the way she turned out to be a
terrible jurist so
not not a great comparison to bring up
right now she upheld roe versus wade
okay so not if you're trying to win over
conservatives here not not a great
argument
but
but beyond that reagan gave americans
the ability to say i picked the best
candidate and she happens to be a woman
and how great is that what an
achievement there's no achievement here
for whichever black woman gets the
nomination because joe biden's saying
you were you were always going to get it
i was never going to consider anyone
else you haven't accomplished anything
i'm just giving this to you people don't
really like that very much
the left is
calling this
they're accusing conservatives here of
playing
identity politics
this has gone so far even the adl the
anti-defamation league
has now just changed the definition of
racism so the old old definition of
racism from the adl racism is the belief
that a particular race is superior or
inferior to another that a person's
social and moral traits are
predetermined by his or her inborn
biological characteristics racial
separatism is the belief most of the
time based on racism
that different races should remain
segregated and apart from one another
the new definition according to the adl
the marginalization and or oppression of
people of color based on a socially
constructed racial hierarchy
the privilege privileges white people
so the old definition was racism the new
definition
anything white people do
two people of color can never go the
other way around when your definition of
racism
becomes an example
of racism you know that you are fully
living
in clown world
we are living in a regime
in a society in which
the truth
is is so divorced from the way that the
government operates that people are
really pressing back against that you're
seeing this in popular movements and
it's not just among rock-ribbed
right-wing republicans it's among a
whole lot of people
this is an election year republicans can
capitalize on this conservatives can
capitalize on this if they have the
courage to do it
not sure not sure i would hold my breath
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show enemies of
joe rogan activate to get spotify to
cancel him that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen